in this video we'll be explaining all 24
jujutsu sorcerers in jiu jitsu kaizen we
will start with miwa who we consider to
be the weakest and by the end of the
video we'll be covering some insanely
strong sorcerers miwa is a grade 3
sorcerer capable of using the new shadow
style swordsmanship techniques we first
see miwa in action during the kyoto
goodwill event when she battles against
maki she quickly realizes that maki is
incredibly strong and states that she
needs to turn this battle into close
combat maki swings the spear in a 360
motion unleashing a slash that mew miwa
barely guards if this had been a real
fight and maki really tried to kill her
meewa would have died twice already in
order to gain some ground she steps back
and activates new shadow style simple
domain in order to counter this maki
breaks her own spear and throws it at
her meewa deflects the broken spear but
is nearly hit by an unexpected kunai
using the hidden weapons to close the
gap maki gets in close and disarms her
over sword stay tuned because we still
have 23 interesting sorcerers to cover
number 23 nishimiya momo momo is a
semi-grade 2 sorcerer that's speculated
by panda she possesses a curse technique
that allows her to stay mobile and
collect information via her ability to
levitate momo was able to compete with
nobara thanks to her experience by
staying out of range momo made it
difficult for nobar to reach her with
any of her attacks she hasn't really
done anything important since then so
we're going to leave it at that before
we continue any further we want to thank
dragon city for sponsoring this video
check out dragon city by clicking the
first link in the description dragon
city is a free free-to-play game where
you can collect thousands of dragons
with different elements and rarities and
build your own dragon empire you will
need to collect food gold and gems so
that you can tailor your city and to
reach new levels you can breed two
dragons and get new ones hatch them and
feed them to evolve then you can train
your dragons to take them to battle in
order to make them more powerful want to
test the strength of your dragons just
go to the arena fights where you can
challenge your friends and other dragon
masters you can also become a member of
an alliance interact with other masters
join exclusive events and unlock special
rewards there are several special events
every week and a brand new battle pass
where you can claim new prizes and
dragons daily you will also find the
dragons of your favorite youtubers like
dream george not found unspeakable and
others click the link in the description
to download dragon city now and get a
free starter pack of fifteen thousand
food thirty thousand gold and the
iceland dragon thank you dragon city for
supporting the channel and let's get
back to the video number 22 my zenin mai
is a twin sister of maki she uses a
handgun as her main weapon it is capable
of infusing her bullets with cursed
energy with just one direct hit she is
able to take down a fellow sorcerer or a
curse despite keeping up the facade that
she is more powerful than her sister she
does not possess the physical skills to
contend with her additionally her curse
technique is unrefined and can only be
used once a day mai is a very crude and
straightforward person who takes out her
desire to not be a sorcerer on others
this attitude comes from mai's desire to
live a normal life enter trauma of
abandonment after twin sister maki left
the family mai and her sister were both
raised in the zenon household looked
down upon for being women and for
possessing little cursed energy while
mai was content living there maki
decided to leave and become a sorcerer
breaking her promise to always stay with
mai to avoid any backlash from the zenon
family mai was left with no choice but
to attempt to become a sorcerer as well
for someone who never wanted to become a
jujutsu sorcerer in the first place mai
is very intelligent and skilled in
combat proving her worth among great
three sorcerers keep watching since
there are still over 20 fascinating
sorcerers left to cover number 21 muta
kokichi muda can control several puppets
at once remotely from a great distance
with each puppet possessing high combat
abilities worthy enough to earn him his
semi-grade 1 rank muda is a highly
tactical thinker and fighter who tries
to always stay a step ahead of his
opponent while in combat with panda muta
ascertained panda's strengths and
weaknesses as well as his own at every
stage of the fight sudo ghetto also
praised muta for having decent tactical
prowess while fighting mojito he was
well prepared for their fight and his
tactics nearly succeeded in wearing
mojito out and damaging his body while
neutralizing his technique in order to
defeat mohito muda was prepared to
unleash his entire life's worth of
cursed energy reserves to win it was
nearly enough to exercise the special
grade curse but he was ultimately
defeated because mojito was able to lure
him into a false sense of security after
believing he had achieved his objective
the next character on our list is one of
my personal favorites and it's none
other than panda panda is a grade 2
sorcerer and a mutated cursed corpse the
most advanced of his kind he was created
by principal masamichi yaga with a
natural affinity for jiu jitsu panda is
capable of exercising curses based
solely on his physical abilities he is
highly intelligent and able to think
strategically always staying one step
ahead of his opponents the only way to
take him down is by destroying the cores
of cursed energy that act as his heart
additionally his body is extremely
durable and can be reinforced using
jujutsu protection panda has also proven
to be a very powerful puncher even able
to stun toto with the right hook as well
as batter mcamaru with straight punches
panda's physiology as a cursed corpse
allowed him to absorb high amounts of
damage he was able to easily brush off
makimaru's ultra cannon and even took
the brunt of his opponent's strongest
ability and survived in that same battle
panda fooled makamaru multiple times by
faking an injury to his cores and won
because his opponent underestimated his
intelligence as further credits to his
skill even suguru ghetto a sorcerer with
immense tactical reasoning was surprised
by panda's cleverness in battle number
19. ino tsukuma ino is a grade 2
sorcerer but his rank does not reflect
his true skill level according to
anatomy eno could easily become a
semi-grade 1 sorcerer if he chose to he
is an exceptional combatant with a very
potent curse technique eno actively
chooses to stay at grade 2 until he gets
naomi's approval and doesn't always have
confidence in himself however naomi was
completely sure eno could take out a
large room full of transfigured humans
and left him there alone to take care of
them he even believed eno could exercise
mojito in his weakened state during the
shibuya incident arc ino was assigned to
anonymity's team and was eventually put
in charge of leading yuji and megumi he
worked together with the squad to deduce
the enemy curse user's location and was
able to fight two of them at once after
confronting them eno is an expert in
hand-to-hand combat and can outclass an
average curse user with no issue however
he caught on to his opponent's plan too
late allowing granny ogimi to
outmaneuver him and activate her seance
technique after her grandson
shape-shifted into toji fushiguru eno
proved to be no match for him in terms
of physical prowess which is
understandable since it was you know
toji fujiguru number 18 noritoshi kamo
noritoshi is a semi grade 1 sorcerer
with the ability to use the combo
family's inherited technique blood
manipulation he is a skilled marksman
who incorporates jujutsu into his
archery noritoshi is respected as a
leader among his peers thanks to his
maturity and high tactical mind during
the goodwill event noritoshi acted as
the leader of the kyoto team and led
them into battle against yuji the ambush
was sudden and might have been effective
if not for toto's interference when the
group was forced to retreat noritoshi
was quick to order his allies to secure
their main information gatherer momo who
had been compromised while fighting
megami noritoshi strategically blocked
megami's view in order to get close and
engage in hand-to-hand combat with the
shikigami user in the battle against
hanami noritoshi knew that the students
stood no chance against him and that
their best bet would be to use their
curse techniques to try to stall hanumi
although noratoshi was eventually
defeated he was a key reason megumi was
able to discover hanami's weakness
number 17. gugi saki nabara nabara is a
first-year student and grade through
jujutsu sorcerer at tokyo jujutsu high
studying under satoru gojo nabarro has
showcased numerous times the capability
to fight against sorcerers much above
her rank coming into school nabarro had
a solid understanding of how to exercise
curses with her innate technique she
also had the mental fortitude to handle
the job but lacked physical ability
while fighting in the detention center
nabarra defended herself adequately
until she ran out of nails to fight with
afterward maki took nabara under her
wing and trained her to improve her
physical prowess during the kyoto
goodwill event nobara fought against
momo she was knocked down several times
by gusts of cursed energy but eventually
found a way to counter attack alongside
yuji nobara was able to fight on equal
grounds against esso and kichizu both
students were poisoned by the death
painting's blood technique but nabarro
used that connection against her enemies
nabarro's adaptability and fearlessness
led her to use resonance on herself to
injure esso and kachizu at the same time
this involved stabbing herself with
nails to activate resonance but she was
more than happy to do so the poison as
well as the pain from stabbing herself
helps nobara enter a state of extreme
focus allowing her to unleash the power
of black flash as well nabara and yuji
defeated the death painting prompting
meimei and toto to recommend her and all
her peers for grade 1. during the
shibuya incident arc nabarro faces off
against mojito she realizes that he has
a very strong opponent and that she
needs to fully focus initially it seems
that mojito has the upper hand only to
be shocked when nabarro's resonance
ability attacks his soul directly the
damage of nabarro's attacks on the clone
resonates with the original and bounces
back to the clone leaving them both
stunned suddenly mojito transfigures
nabara's face blasting it open and
destroying one of her eyes even though
it seems that nobara died she is still
to be confirmed to be dead or alive in
the manga number 16 fushiguru megumi
megumi is one of the main characters in
the show he showed on many occasions
that he is one of the most talented jiu
jitsu sorcerers in the world megumi
entered jiu jitsu high as a grade 2
sorcerer and is considered to have high
potential by noritoshi mai gojo and even
tsukuna the king of curses notes that
megumi's willingness to use hand-to-hand
combat makes him different from other
shikigami users as he is able to use his
physical attacks in combination with the
shikigami to entrap his opponents
according to gojo megumi has equal or
even greater potential skill than yuji
and later implies that megumi could even
be on par with him someday one major
reason physical fitness is a necessity
for megumi is the fact that his
signature curse technique manifests
entirely separated from himself megami's
most frequently used ability in battle
is his 10 shadows technique inherited
from the zenon family his bloodline in
practice it allows him to summon
friendly cursed spirits that will fight
alongside him in his battles megumi
first activates his domain expansion
technique called kamira shadow garden
during his fight against finger bearer
within megami's domain the entirety of
the ground is covered by the shadowy
liquid from which his curse companions
can emerge not only does this allow him
to call upon his allies with greater
ease but it can even summon more than
one of the same shikigami at once
against his opponent megami summons
multiple toads while using the openings
they create to land physical attacks
making use of many of his combat skills
at once megumi plays a huge part in the
shibuya incident arc as he battles
against many cursed spirits and also
against the reincarnation of his own
father toji fushiguru megumi also
managed to summon general maharaga the
most powerful shikigami of the ten
shadows technique when sukuna arrives at
the site he finds megumi in a state of
suspended death sukuno then heals megumi
and says that he still needs him for
something once maharaja is dealt with
sukuna brings megumi to where masamichi
and shoko are at due to sakuna's great
interest in megami he is definitely a
character to keep an eye on in future
episodes the next character on our list
is none other than the beloved
protagonist yuji iridori yuji is one of
his school's most powerful and talented
students gojo placing him on the same
level of potential as yuda and kinji as
one of the three students who he
believes can surpass his strength
despite having no connections to the
jujutsu world a few months prior to the
shibuya incident yuji is able to contend
with in defeat grade 1 in special grade
curses he was gifted with superhuman
physical abilities which he masterfully
combines with his cursed energy yuji is
also able to contain sukuna which
enables him to harm mojito who is
otherwise resistant to injuries as
powerful as he is especially when it
comes to fighting his inhuman strength
can often be augmented to further levels
with the usage of both the divergent
fist and the black flash allowing him to
exercise cursed spirits he can even harm
hanomy and chozo two curses who are
remarkable for their durability and
toughness with the former being near
impossible to damage during the shibuya
incident arc yuji makes a real statement
he shows great skill in combat against
cho so and later proves to be on a
similar level as grade 1 sorcerers by
almost killing mojito all by himself
yuji will surely surpass most of his
classmates in the future and potentially
become one of the strongest jujutsu
sorcerers to ever exist number 14 laurie
udahime udahime lori is a semi-grade 1
jujutsu sorcerer and student supervisor
a kyoto jujutsu high during kyoto
goodwill event utahime meets up with the
other staff members to watch the event
when mii was put to sleep by toge
udahime becomes worried and decides to
go get her when all the talismans
suddenly burn red the spectators all
believe that there is an intruder
udahime along with gojo and yoshinobu
decide to head over to the site to deal
with the problem as the three were
approaching they noticed that a screen
is covering the site they decide to test
out the screen and find that gojo is the
only one that can't enter both udahime
and yoshinobu head inside once inside
the two encounter juzo yoshinobu decides
to stay and fight him alone while
udahime goes to look for the students as
she heads towards the students she
encounters haruda another intruder mai
and nobara show up to a sister but the
screen is suddenly lifted causing the
enemy to run away number 13 inumaki toge
toge is considered to be among the
strongest and most respected jujutsu
students his curse techniques and
athletic abilities have earned him a
strong reputation among the students and
even ghetto believed he was a sorcerer
blessed with great potential toge is
highly intelligent with high stamina as
well as an expert in wielding his
powerful curse technique alongside
stamina curse speech requires a high
degree of cursed energy especially if
toge faces off against a powerful curse
his very presence on the battlefield
makes it difficult for anyone to focus
due to the nature of his technique while
overusing his ability creates backlash
to his body toge can still unleash
attacks capable of affecting special
great curses as well toge possesses the
snake and fang seal of the inumaki clan
on his tongue and around both sides of
his mouth this allows touge to infuse
his words with cursed energy but even
less powerful words will consume more
energy and stamina when used against
opponents with more cursed energy than
toge number 12 kutsukabe atsuya
kutsukabe is a grade 1 jujutsu sorcerer
and instructs the second year students
at tokyo jujutsu high despite not
possessing an innate technique kutsukawe
is a respected sorcerer and a master
swordsman of the new shadow style meimei
regarded kutsukabe as the only sorcerer
of his rank to make that rank without an
innate technique kutsukabe only admits
on several occasions he has no chance of
defeating a special grade and avoids
them at all costs however he is fully
confident he can defeat other opponents
who are considered to be below his level
while several jujutsu sorcerers were
fighting to get prison realm from sudo
ghetto kutsukai intervened just in time
to save the lives of all his allies sudo
ghetto even claimed that he was the
first one to enter the battle with
actual skill kitsuka's swordplay is his
main weapon in battle relying heavily on
physical prowess in combination with the
swordsmanship techniques of the new
shadow he had showcased high proficiency
in wielding his blade using sword
drawing kutsukabe made short work of
three curse users in an instant number
11. yaga masamichi masamichi is the
principal of tokyo jujutsu high the
creator of panda and the former
headmaster of gojo ghetto and shoko his
influence on the sorcerer's world is
massive as a sorcerer he has high levels
of cursed energy which he uses to make
and control puppets to attack his
enemies this cursed energy depending on
how it is used allows the doll to come
to life for a limited amount of time the
most basic of these cursed corpses
follow relatively simple commands for
instance one of yaga's dolls tsukimoto
is a small bear with boxing gloves that
constantly sleeps as long as it has a
constant flow of cursed energy poured
into it disrupt that flow and the bear
will wake up and beat the tar out of
whoever is holding it however yaga isn't
just some run-of-the-mill puppeteer he's
the foremost expert in the world on
cursed corpses and has made the only
known cursed corpse that is ostensibly
its own person this cursed corpse is
named panda and is actually one of the
students at tokyo jujutsu high by
inserting three instead of the normal
one jujutsu imbued cores into panda yaga
is able to attune them so that panda
becomes something more than a mere doll
during the perfect preparation arc
masamichi is confronted by yoshinobu the
two get into a fight with masamiji being
defeated and heavily wounded number 10
naobito zenon naobito zenin is a grade 1
jujutsu sorcerer the 26 head of the
xenon family and the father of naoya at
first glance he appears lazy and more
interested in drinking than fighting but
this same person can effortlessly
overpower a special great cursed spirit
in close quarters exchanges his innate
technique coupled with his capacity for
martial arts and knack for strategic
timing got now abito recognized as the
fastest jiu jitsu sorcerer with the
exception of gojo of course the head of
the zenon family was chose to lead a
team of sorcerers during the shibuya
incident while disinterested at first
now abito proved crucial in the early
efforts to rescue gojo from the prison
realm while fighting dagon naiobito
saved maki from certain death when one
of her attacks failed and even
outperformed anonymity throughout the
early battle now abito was able to read
and react to dagen's growing strength
throughout their fight he recognized
that dagon had far more cursed energy
and cursed techniques than himself but
he still had him far outclassed with
speed with support from naomi and maki
now beto was able to completely
overwhelm dagen with one crushing blow
after another not even wasting a second
in between the attacks he openly
admitted that now be to speed was the
reason he couldn't fight back and
resorted to using domain expansion
trapped inside the domain now abito was
the only one on the team able to
effectively counter their domain and
granted automatic hit once the domain's
guaranteed hit was nullified now abito
was able to effectively fight back
against the curse again the team chose
to attempt to flee and accidentally let
in a recently revived toji fushiguru now
abito supported toji at the end of the
fight by not allowing dagon to escape
afterward the sorcerers were unfortunate
enough to happen upon joga maki anonymi
were instantly set aflame by the curse
but now beto was able to avoid his
initial attack however he too was
blasted by jogo's flames and defeated
eventually succumbing to his wounds and
dying number nine aoi toto toto is an
exceptionally powerful sorcerer
undoubtedly one of jiujitsuhai's
strongest students he obtained the rank
of a grade one sorcerer despite coming
from a non-sorcerer family toto
single-handedly defeated five grade one
cursed spirits and even one special
grade during ghetto's nightline attack
in kyoto this feat became well known
around the jujutsu community and caused
the rumor that toto defeated all six
curses without his cursed technique toto
possesses physical strength that
surpasses maki and pandas and rivals
yuji's prowess using brute force in
fierce martial arts is able to easily
overwhelm megumi as well as pommel yuji
in the early stages of their fight even
after beginning to guide yuji on how to
become stronger toto maintained the
upper hand while fighting due to his
experience and cleverness his
understanding of cursed energy allowed
him to teach yuji how to properly use it
alongside his superhuman speed and
strength during the battle against
autonomy toto was able to analyze all
his moves and instantly create ways to
counter them using his own curse
techniques during the shibuya incident
arc justice mojito was about to execute
a distressed yuji toto appeared just in
time to save him using boogie woogie to
swap positions with mojito toto goes on
to fight against mojito he loses one of
his arms in the process but manages to
survive in the end number eight meimei
meimei is a grade one sorcerer
recognized by many for being more than a
capable fighter gojo has stated in the
past that he believes meimei is strong a
comment that the strongest sorcerer
doesn't hand out lightly meimei
originally believed she was born with a
weak innate technique because it only
allowed her to control birds and that
was it as a result she trained herself
to be effective without it crafting
herself into a close quarters combatant
thanks to the straining maemie was
effortlessly able to defeat niji a curse
user believed to be as strong as the
semi-grade one right after killing him
mimi had to face his special grade
disease curse summoned via cursed spirit
manipulation the smallpox deity trapped
maymay within its domain expansion with
conditions that could kill her in just
three seconds she claimed that she
couldn't remember the last time her life
was in danger before this suggesting
that she hadn't been defeated or injured
in a long time while working as a
sorcerer despite the overwhelming
disadvantage maymay was able to defeat
the special grade curse with her younger
brother's help her intellect and combat
experience helped her outmaneuver the
cursed spirit and exercise it this feat
even impressed sudo ghetto who admitted
meimei was exceptional for a jiu jitsu
sorcerer of the modern era number seven
kentonami nanami was a former student of
tokyo jujutsu high where he was an
underclassman of satoru gojo and suguru
ghetto anonymity initially left jiu
jitsu high after graduating to become a
salaryman but returned four years later
to continue working as a sorcerer while
working as a sorcerer naomi was ranked
grade one and operated primarily out of
the tokyo campus with gojo's
introduction he also became a close
mentor to yuji nanami is a model example
of what a grade one jiu jitsu sorceress
should be yuji and ino both look up to
nanome for his attitude when approaching
difficult situations as well as this
incredible skill when it comes down to
solving them gojo entrusted nanome with
looking after yuji due to these traits
and it paid off well for yuji's growth
eno a powerful grade two sorcerer
approaches every tough decision with
what would nanome do in mind because he
believes anatomy always handles things
the right way when it comes to combat
ability nanome is capable of fighting on
par with special great cursed spirits
such as mojito while mojito was still in
the infancy of his existence naomi was
able to keep up in several of the
exchanges with the lack of information
on majito's ability nanami suffered a
direct blow to his soul but was still
able to survive something no one majido
faced before was able to do mojito
himself considered naomi to be an
exceptionally strong and a worthy
opponent far stronger than the average
sorcerer during the shibuya incident
naomi showcases leadership abilities
alongside great intellect and fighting
strength upon learning about gojo's
ceiling nanome was able to deduce what
would be the best move for his team and
helped carry out mekamaru's rescue plan
without delay he then battles against
mojito for the second time but
unfortunately the cursed spirit was much
stronger than before and anonymity died
fighting it number six maki zemen if
there was ever an example of the word
underrated maki would definitely be it
maki is a grade four sorcerer and member
of the zenon family she is currently a
second year at tokyo jujutsu high maki's
ranking is not at all reflective of her
actual ability in battle her promotion
was stalled for years and she can easily
exercise a grade 2 curse her physical
prowess is second only to yuji itadori's
among the students and she is a master
of a wide assortment of different
weapons maki doesn't possess any cursed
energy but she more than compensates for
it using cursed tools compared to other
jujutsu students maki is often
underestimated however she was able to
effortlessly overwhelm miwa as well as
completely dominate her sister in a
fight maki has proven to be a valuable
asset in the battle against special
grade cursed spirits she and megumi were
able to buy enough time against hanami
for reinforcements to arrive while
fighting alongside naobito anonymi
against dagen maki was a step slower
than the experienced grade 1 sorcerers
but was still able to hold her own and
assist them in battle during the perfect
preparation arc maki enters the
warehouse at the zenon family house she
is greeted by her father ogie who tells
her that he's already disposed of all
the tools maki spots a wounded mind
behind her father and prepares to fight
him after a brief exchange of blows maki
breaks og's katana she attempts to
deliver the final blow however og
recreates his blade and slashes her
flank he drags both of his beaten up
daughters to the training room full of
her spirits and throws them in mai says
that she knew that twins are auspicious
for sorcerers in order to gain something
one must sacrifice something she then
proceeds to sacrifice herself in order
for maki to get stronger oh gee feels a
strange sensation emerging from the
training room he turns around and
notices that all of the cursed spirits
have vanished ogi then feels an old
sensation that he tried to forget the
fear of toji xenon which he sees in maki
a frightened doji unleash just innate
technique blazing courage it means to
burn her down with his own two hands as
he challenges her to a fight she quickly
cuts his head in two killing him with
her new sword she tells mai that they
shall begin afterward maki goes on to
slaughter the entire zenin clan killing
many high-ranking sorcerers in the
process it's evident that maki is very
close to being a special great sorcerer
but until we see the full potential of
her power we can't rank her any higher
than this number 5. yuda okatsu yuda
okatsu is the main protagonist of jiu
jitsu kaizen zero he was initially a
special great cursed human haunted by
his late childhood friend riko orimoto
gojo mentored yuta and enrolled him at
tokyo jujutsu high he was training
overseas in africa with miguel until
after the shibuya incident when he
returned to tokyo yuda is one of four
special great sorcerers recognized by
jiu jitsu high he apparently dominated
all of the kyoto students in the 2017
goodwill event and was able to defeat
suguru ghetto after releasing the
limiters on rika's power after training
with gojo and the other students yuda
learns to control his cursed energy and
becomes reliable with the sword even
after rika's curse is dispelled yuda
still retains his special grade ranking
gojo even stated that yud has the
potential to surpass his power in the
future yuta's great power comes from
being a descendant of one of the big
three vengeful spirits of japan it is
the reason he cursed rika when he
rejected her death at a young age since
his return to japan yuta has become a
masterful jujutsu sorcerer entrusted by
the jujutsu higher-ups to handle curses
and execute sukuna's vessel upon
confronting yuji nawya and joso both
exceptional jujutsu users recognized
that yuda was far more powerful than
them noe especially who prides himself
on his abilities quickly allied himself
to yudah to avoid any potential conflict
joso advised yuji to run at all costs
because fighting yuta would ensure his
death comparing his strength to satoru
gojo's number four yuki tsukumo while
her current abilities are unknown it is
safe to assume that yuki is one of the
strongest sorcerers in the series she
was also a mentor of toto a powerful
first grade sorcerer yuki was able to
save the others from rami's ice ball
technique by blocking it with ease
besides this there isn't much to go by
while trying to evaluate her strength at
this point we can only imagine how
powerful she really is number three
suguru ghetto suguru ghetto is an
antagonist in jiu jitsu kaizen's zero
jujutsu high he was originally
masamichi's students alongside gojo and
shoko his experience as a jujutsu
sorcerer bred a deep hatred for
non-sorcerers leading to an instant
regatta massacred over a hundred
civilians in a single night ghetto is
one of only four special great sorcerers
and was deemed the worst of all curse
users due to the level of danger he
presented to humanity while they were
students at jiu jitsu high ghetto and
gojo were both considered the strongest
he was capable of making short work of
experienced curse users on multiple
occasions with little to no effort his
collection of her spirits was wide with
a high variety of different abilities
and roles in battle ghetto was not
overly dependent on his curses and was a
highly capable close quarters fighter as
well during his time as a curse user
ghetto used his religious group as
allure to collect thousands of cursed
spirits over the course of a decade he
became a bigger threat to humanity than
any curse of the time with thousands of
curses and several cursed users by his
side ghetto had enough power behind him
to declare war on jujutsu high the
cornerstone of the jujutsu community he
understood that despite all his
resources he had a low chance of
defeating all the jujutsu high sorcerers
his tactical intellect allowed him to
deceive them and isolate yuta at the
school itself ghetto's true goal was to
kill yuda and steal special grade
vengeful spirit rika from him if his
curses were not split between two
different locations it is believed that
ghetto would have been successful number
two kenjaku kanjaku is an ancient
sorcerer who pursues the goal of
evolving humanity via cursed energy
thereby creating a new golden age of
jujutsu sorcery using the curse
technique that allows him to transplant
his brain into different bodies to
possess them he has inhabited different
people throughout the centuries assuming
different identities among those he has
possessed noritoshigamo over 150 years
ago with this identity he was known as
history's most evil sorcerer and a stain
on the kamo family currently kanjaku
possesses the body of the sisuguru
ghetto whom he chose for his cursed
spirit manipulation and has assumed his
identity as sudo ghetto as a thousand
year old sorcerer he possesses
incredible knowledge about curses curse
techniques and the jujutsu world overall
he was stated by tengen to be the second
most powerful barrier user after himself
in ghetto's body he has led a group of
incredibly powerful special grid curses
and made them into a functioning team
capable of being a great threat to the
jujutsu world and japan kanjaku's
greatest asset however is his immense
amount of intelligence and planning he
can lay plans which are so advanced they
can go on for centuries before being
completed in the modern age he is the
mastermind behind mojito's group in the
entire shibuya incident including the
eventual sealing of gojo satoru with his
immense skill and knowledge he can
easily defeat any of the previously
mentioned sorcerers but there is one guy
not even kenjaku can defeat which leads
us to first place on our list number one
gojo satoru even among the special great
sorcerers gojo is known to be the
strongest sorcerer in the series holding
both immense amounts of cursed energy
and a dangerously powerful technique as
a student gojo was capable of making
short work of experience in powerful
curse users after perfecting his skills
gojo's ability vastly increased to where
he was able to put toji fushiguru into
the defensive and ultimately kill him
with his strongest technique as he
continued to grow he eclipsed ghetto's
might to where ghetto admitted that gojo
has truly become the strongest ghetto
stated that gojo had the capability of
killing all of humanity by himself and
didn't even try to fight back when gojo
prepared to kill him in the present
gojo's might was feared by the
higher-ups of the jujutsu society to
where he could easily force them to
cancel the execution of a special great
sorcerer yuda in the sukuna's vessel
yuji he states that it would be easy for
him to kill them all and overthrow the
jujutsu society if he wanted to he even
claimed that he could defeat sukuna at
his full power kanjaku and his group of
extremely strong special great cursed
spirits were also wary of gojo's power
and skill with kanjaku admitting he
couldn't defeat gojo in direct battle he
was capable of completely overpowering
jogo the strongest curse in kinjaku's
group and simply his presence was able
to force hanami to retreat when konjaco
and his group finally developed a plan
to face him in combat despite their
preparations gojo was still capable of
easily fending off their assaults and
overpowering them leaving them astounded
with how powerful he is he managed to
overpower every special great curse
spirit in kanjaku's group at the same
time killing hanumi in the process he
was only defeated due to kinjaku using
his pass with ghetto to distract him for
long enough for the prison realm to seal
him don't forget to check out dragon
city and claim your free starter pack by
clicking the first link in the
description also click on this video to
see all the things you missed in jiu
jitsu kaizen